- Thanks to Express VPN
for keeping Legal Eagle
safe and in the air.
In the wake of systemic police abuse
that was brought to a head by
what we saw with George Floyd,
people are out in the streets
and they are demanding police reform.
And it's an idea whose time has come.
But apart from just entirely
disbanding the police,
what can we possibly do?
Well, as an officer of the court,
I have some ideas.
(dramatic music)
Hey, legal eagles, it's
time to think like a lawyer,
because it appears that the time has come
or true police reform.
- We cannot settle for anything less
than transformative structural change.
- A broad coalition of people
are working to change the way
that police departments operate.
Legislators are writing bills.
State and local governments,
as well as the federal government
seem to have heard those cries
and appear to be amenable for something
that was completely off the table
just a few short months ago.
But that raises the question,
if we're going to change
the way the police operate,
what exactly are we going to do?
The good and bad news is that
a lot of the reforms that
people are calling for
are very easy to implement.
It only take the political will to do so.
And changing the way the police operate
can be a very, very difficult task
in a political economy.
And traditionally speaking,
politicians love the police.
It's hard to lose an election battle
if you are on the side
of the police department.
- We have to respect our police,
we have to take care of our police.
They're protecting us.
- And being tough on crime.
Which is one of the reasons why
it's been so difficult to
usher in police reform.
But perhaps the time is now.
There seems to be a
broad coalition growing
and calling for real concrete steps.
And the good news is there's tons of
low hanging fruit for police reform
that will lead to more just outcomes
for almost everyone,
and more just policing.
But before we dive into
some of these reforms,
some of which I think
are complete no-brainers,
let's talk for a second about the problems
with maximalism and trade-offs.
Because in this debate
people want different things.
Some people want safety, low crime.
Others want human dignity and justice.
Tax payers want low cost and low taxes.
Some people want higher enforcement
of crimes and punishment rates.
Police officers often want job safety,
and other individuals want privacy.
And a lot of these different things
are at odds with each other.
And we have to recognize that,
when you turn one of these dials,
the other dials move.
So, it's possible that
some of these reforms
might cost more tax money.
Some of these reforms might result in
fewer crimes being punished
when the crime actually occurs.
Some of these reforms might cause
police officers to be
less safe in their jobs.
And these are all trade-offs.
I'm not here to choose which one
is more important than the other.
But all of these dials move in
conjunction with each other,
and there are going to be trade-offs
with some of these particular reforms.
I happen to personally believe that
we should move the dial in terms of
justice and fairness with
respect to individual citizens.
And if that means some higher costs,
well, that might be a
trade-off that's worth while.
But it would be very silly to claim that
all of these reforms are
going to be a free lunch.
There's no such thing as a free lunch.
But let's talk about some of the reforms
that are in the air.
I'm not here to advocate for any
particular one of these,
but I think a lot of
these potential reforms
have the potential to
really be a game-changer
when it comes to justice and fairness
throughout America when
it comes to the police.
So, in no particular order,
here are some ideas that really
could make a huge difference when
it comes to fairness and the police.
First, body cameras.
A lot of jurisdictions
don't have body cameras.
Luckily there are a
lot of federal programs
that help provide funding to
local municipal police departments
so that they can provide body cameras
when it wouldn't otherwise
be in the budget.
But the technology exists for body cameras
on police officers to record basically
continuously while that
police officer is patrolling.
And it seems crazy that the police officer
would have the control to be able to
turn off and on the body camera at whim.
And we've seen instances where
police officers have actually
planted drugs on suspects
and then turn their body
camera on minutes later.
And the only reason we know that is
that the police officer didn't know
that the body camera had
a prerecord functionality.
But let's do away with all of that
and just have body
cameras on all the time.
And there could be penalties
for police officers
that intentionally block or turn off
their body cameras
during important events.
And this is one reform that I think
most police officers
should be in favor of.
Because, while the cultural zeitgeist
is full of horrific accounts
of police misconduct,
especially in the wake
of peaceful protests,
it'd be silly to think that all of the
complaints against the
police are meritorious.
In fact, probably, the
majority of the complaints
that are made against the
police are not meritorious
and are probably made by criminals
who are not happy with the fact
that they were arrested.
So, having footage of interactions
with potential suspects where the police
can clearly show that they
engaged in no misconduct
inures to the benefits
of the police as well.
And next is the issue of public access
to information regarding
police misconduct.
Now, we've already acknowledged that
some police misconduct or allegations
of police misconduct is
completely fabricated.
But also, some of that information
is absolute not fabricated,
and we have to admit that the
police engage in misconduct.
And it's important that because
police are public servants
that not just convictions
regarding police misconduct,
but also even allegations
of police misconduct
be made available to both the cities
and the people who those cities serve.
And the statistics tend
to bear this out as well.
Only a small number of police officers
are responsible for the vast majority
of allegations and convictions
of police misconduct.
So, it's very important to have
access to that data, that information
to know who those
potential bad apples are.
- You always have a bad
apple no matter where you go.
You have bad apples, and there
are not too many of them.
And I can tell you, there are not too
many of them in the police department.
- And by the way, the
metaphor of the bad apples
that's being thrown around a lot,
especially by police officers
and police departments
claiming that it's only
a couple of bad apples.
Well, remember, that analogy is that
a handful of bad apples will spoil
the entire barrel of of apples.
So, when you have a
potential systemic issue,
the fact that you're pointing to
a couple of bad apples doesn't actually
support your argument
that it's individuals
and not the system itself.
Because those couple of bad actors,
those bad apples can have
a corrupting influence
on the rest of the entire department.
So, be careful what metaphors you use
and in what particular context.
It's important to know
what those words mean.
But even if we were to take the idea
that these are isolated individuals
that don't have a larger systemic issue,
one of the more meta things
that police departments
I think should do is inculcate
this culture of weeding out the bad apples
from the rest of the department.
Certainly, there are
going to be individuals
who are worse than other individuals,
and they might have a
corrupting influence.
And the stats bear out that they might
be responsible for more of the
misconduct than other people.
So, if you are a good police officer
who is not engaging in misconduct,
you should want to get
those other people out.
But what we've seen is that this blue wall
or this blue line prevents
getting out the bad actors.
So, I would like to see, and I don't know
how one would accomplish this per se,
but police departments
should have a culture
of weeding out the bad apples,
because they shouldn't be there.
One way you might do that is by having
a whistle blower system that tends to
exist on the federal level.
Though that's being eroded day-by-day.
Still, the idea of whistle blowers
or providing rewards to individuals
who are willing to buck the trend
of the rest of the department
to be able to report and get rid of
bad actors where they exist.
I think that that is a
very meritorious system,
a good philosophy, and I don't know
how one would do that, but it's something
that police departments should aspire to.
Though, on the other side,
if that is the carrot
in terms of getting people
to report bad behavior,
the stick portion of that
would be a duty to report,
such that if you witness
bad conduct taking place,
and this does exist in
some police departments,
then the individual officers have
a duty to report that
bad conduct up the chain
or to investigative affairs.
But you could take a two-pronged approach.
You can reward whistle
blowers who come forward,
and you can also create a duty to report
such that individual officers are liable
when they fail to report
egregious conduct.
But when you're talking about
the culture of the police department,
it's impossible to overlook
the elephant in the room,
and that's police unions.
This is probably one potential avenue
that's going to be the most divisive,
even amongst people that want
to reform police departments.
But there is no argument
that police unions
have a huge amount of power.
And partly, it's by design.
Police unions are designed
so that they create
collective bargaining power
so that they can help police officers
get more favorable working conditions
and more favorable terms
under which they work.
The downside to that is that
the police union has as a client
its police officers.
- I will defend those that stand here.
I will defend my family.
I will defend our citizens, both here
and who are now in phase
one going back to work.
- And often, what's in the best interest
of the community is not
in the best interest
of the police officers themselves
or the police union at large.
And part of the issue here is that
some of the things that the police unions
often negotiate over
are not just things like
salary, or hours, or retirement benefits,
but things like what happens when
individual police officers
are accused of misconduct.
Often, you'll see in the
collective bargaining agreements,
that the police officers,
if they are accused of
egregious misconduct,
have a certain cooling off period,
where it might be 48 or 72 hours
before other police officers
are even allowed to
interview the police officers
accused of misconduct of
what actually happened.
And what we have seen is that
during that amount of time,
think about what they're going to say
to the people who are investigating.
They think about getting
their stories straight.
They think about what
particular chain of events
would be most benefitial to themselves.
And it will not surprise you that
if you are a normal citizen who is
accused of criminal misconduct,
you don't get the same kind of protections
that the police do
because of the contracts
that are written into the
collective bargaining agreements
between the police union
and the police departments.
And I've heard stories of police unions
giving individual officers, more or less,
a script to recite when
they are accused of
unlawful use of force.
So, they can get their story to line up
with the thing that is
the best legal defense.
- And the only thing
actually left was my firearm.
This has to work, otherwise
I'm going to be dead.
He's gonna get this gun away from me.
Something gonna happen,
and I'm gonna be dead.
- And these are just a
handful for examples how,
in many ways, police officers
get special treatment
when they are accused of
misconduct on their own.
And that's not to say that police unions
don't provide real benefits.
But if people are really serious about
creating a more just and fair system
for everyone, not just police officers,
certainly people are gonna have to take
a serious look at the
power the police unions
have in this country.
And because of the power the
police unions have in this country,
it's often been incredibly difficult
to get police reforms because,
as a political entity,
they tend to fight any
kind of change at all.
- Beginning today, as chief,
I am immediately withdrawing from
the contract negotiations
with the Minneapolis Police Federation.
I plan to bring in
subject matter experience
and advisors to conduct a thorough review
of how the contract can be restructured
to provide greater community transparency
and more flexibility for true reform.
- So, if we were going to
use a general principle here,
we might say that perhaps there can be
a rule that says police officers
can't get any special treatment
above and beyond what
any other normal citizen
would get when accused
of criminal misconduct.
And when it comes to police oversight,
perhaps we should rethink the idea
that the police are able
to police themselves.
Where instead of the police
overseeing themselves,
there is a board of civilians,
or at least non police officers,
who are able to look at
the potential misconduct
and make a judgment over it.
And perhaps, even better than just
a civilian oversight board
is a civilian oversight board with
the ability to make
high-stakes decisions that,
if they do find misconduct
they are able to
levee penalties against
the police officers
or potentially even fire them.
Now, obviously, this is something that
police unions want to fight against,
because they don't want
some other third party
having sway over
individual police officers,
but it's something that other
police departments have done
and can make sure that,
when there is misconduct,
that the bad actors or punished for it.
And on that score, perhaps and obvious one
is really consequences for bad conduct.
When there is a conviction
for police misconduct
there need to be real stakes so that
individuals are punished for engaging
in that kind of misconduct.
In one way that is sort of in the
cultural zeitgeist these days is
ending or limiting what's
called qualified immunity.
Now, this is a topic for another day.
I'm going to do another set of videos
regarding what's called
a section 1983 claim
under federal law,
which is limited by this
immunity that police
officers often received
called qualified immunity,
which is an impediment
to some federal lawsuits
being served against
individual police officers
and individual police departments.
But, suffice to say, there
are bills before congress
that would abrogate this immunity,
this qualified immunity for the
police officers and police departments.
Which might provide an incentive
to not engage in misconduct or
at least try and curtail it,
because if there are all these lawsuits,
then the police departments
don't want to get defunded.
So, I will cover that in
depth in future videos,
because it's a very,
very complicated subject.
And in terms of the real nuts and bolts,
there is a movement on social
media called 8 Can't Wait,
for eight particular tactics
that a particular group thinks
would make a big difference in terms of
making police departments less violent.
These eight particular tactics include:
banning choke holds outright,
which many police departments have done,
although Minneapolis is a
notable exception to that;
requiring deescalation before
moving forward with violent force;
requiring a warning before shooting;
exhausting all of their
means before shooting;
creating a duty to intervene so that
when police officers
see criminal misconduct
or can help an individual,
they intervene in that situation;
banning shooting at moving vehicles,
requiring a use of force
continuum before escalating;
and requiring comprehensive
reporting of use of force.
I'd recommend taking a deeper dive
into the stats that this movement
has offered about the efficacy.
But there's definitely some potential
in some of these reforms to create
a less violent police department.
Now, in a prior video, I mentioned that
saying police officers are soldiers
in a war for America makes them
sort of feel like soldiers.
And when that happens the police acts
more like soldiers than actual police.
But one of the other reasons why
police officers engage
in additional military
or violent tactics is that they are
clad in all kinds of
surplus military equipment.
Now, one of the reasons that we've
seen that over the last few years
is that there is a federal law
that allows the federal government
to give police departments surplus
military equipment at cost or at no cost,
so long as they use that
equipment within one year.
So, I probably don't need to tell you
that this creates all kinds
of backwards incentives.
Number one, police departments are
going to want to do what they can
to get free military equipment.
And number two, the law
as currently written
incentivizes them to actually use it too
on a use it or lose it basis.
And I'll be the first to admit
that driving around in a
repurposed Humvee or MRAP
looks like a whole lot of fun.
But the last thing that we want to do
is to make police feel like they're
soldiers on the front lines of America.
That's not how you get
just outcomes for citizens.
It's no wonder that
police wearing riot gear
being transported around in troop carriers
feel like soldiers.
And that leads to escalation,
and we've seen that with
peaceful protesters.
And that seems like the very
last thing that we want.
And another potential way to limit
the number of violent encounters
that happened with police,
in sort of outside the box thinking is
perhaps we need to send
non-police sometimes.
In America, pretty much everyone knows
how to dial the police, 911.
But often, the police might not
be the right people, the
right public servants
to send to any given situation.
Perhaps we need to rethink
when we deploy the police.
So, for example, say that someone
is having an issue with someone
who has a mental health issue.
Instead of sending the police,
which is basically the default in America,
perhaps we can send a
non-police health worker,
or a social worker.
That if things escalate,
if things are likely
to get potentially violent,
or if there is a violent
crime potentially perpetrated,
then at that point the
police can be called.
But perhaps the first person who is called
is not a police officer.
But that does remind me of something
that I've seen in
particular in Washington DC,
which is that when police
officers are called,
I think everyone would
agree those officers
need to be clearly identified.
Recently we've seen all kinds of
unidentified military and police officers
roaming the streets of Washington DC
with no clear identification.
And I think a very, very good thing
that pretty much everyone
has a video camera
in their pocket and they're able to
document police misconduct
when it happens,
and we've certainly seen hundreds
if not thousands of examples
of that during the protests.
Obviously, some force
was probably justified
during riots and looting.
But, by and large, the
protests have been peaceful.
So, when you have police using force,
using rubber bullets, using tear gas,
we need to know who these individuals are.
Let alone times when they're using force,
deadly or not, to subdue
potential suspects.
And in terms of protests,
we might consider
banning the use of rubber
bullets and tear gas in general.
It's not clear that the police
have the rules available
to use that kind of equipment responsibly.
Now, obviously, there are times when
there are going to be protests
and riots that are much more violent
than what we've seen as of late.
But perhaps, as a general rule,
or with a very specific
escalation of force,
we might put rules in place that
prevent them from using those
tools in these circumstances.
And of course, it's
important to acknowledge
that police have a dangerous job.
But sometimes that danger is overblown.
If I can digress for a moment,
currently the stats show that
the police officer is the 14th most
dangerous job in the United States.
Somewhere between taxi drivers
and construction workers.
So, sure, being a police officer
might be considered a dangerous job,
but there are many, many other jobs
that are actually much more dangerous
than being a police officer.
And obviously, these individuals
receive none of the kinds of protections
when people accuse them of misconduct.
And one of the more meta things that
definitely strikes close to home
is that we have a lot
of laws in this country.
And theoretically, every single law
that's on the books could result
in someone with a gun
trying to enforce it.
And we've seen relatively
minor infractions
leading to a suspect being killed.
Whether it's kiting checks,
or passing a bad bill, or trying to sell
cigarettes without the
correct certification.
Those are all examples of people
who were accused of minor, minor crimes
that because the police were called,
and admittedly, they
had breached those laws,
they were detained using violent force
and individuals died as a result of those.
So, perhaps we need to rethink
some of the laws that are on the books,
or at the very least, authorization
of using physical or violent force
to detain people who are
accused of very minor crimes.
Now, some people might not like that
because it might lead to
laws being not enforced.
But I think as a society
we need to ask ourselves
what kind of laws justify the potential
for someone dying as a
result of breaching that law.
And since we're on the topic of
police enforcing minor,
sometimes misdemeanor laws,
perhaps we might consider dissociating
the revenue that comes from
those penalties from police departments.
Because often the police departments
directly benefit from that revenue.
It's hard to not think of Ferguson
where there was an entire police culture
of trying to get as much money
from penalties as possible.
Things like speeding tickets
or penalties from misdemeanors.
All of that revenue,
when it was generated,
often from very low income communities,
went directly to the police department.
So, it created this terrible incentive
of being very, very particular about
enforcing everything and getting
as much money as possible
from the community.
So, if the police department didn't
benefit from that revenue,
it might create an incentive
not necessarily to enforce some of
these very low level infractions.
And speaking of the community,
we might want more community
involvement from police.
Some of the police departments that
have done a generally very good job
have been proactive about trying to
make sure that not only the
high level police officers,
but even mid and low level police officers
are involved in the community.
People often talk about requiring police
to live in the areas that
they actively police.
But that's probably more of a proxy
for just knowing the community itself,
knowing who is there,
getting to know those people.
And instead of all police interactions
being only when things have gone wrong,
showing that the police presence
is there to help the community,
to listen to the community, ahead of time,
and really having that
institutional knowledge
instead of waiting for things to go bad
and only having police interactions
being at the point of a gun.
Though one of the issues here is that
often police departments are just
a patchwork quilt throughout
the entire United States
with no overarching guidelines
and no data sharing.
And often the police don't have
the budget to do those sort of things.
So, it might be important for the federal
government to take an oversight role here.
Perhaps there can be a central federal
oversight or data clearinghouse center
where the federal government provides
the funds and the manpower to
gather all of the relevant statistics
and to provide some oversight to
all of the different states
and individual police
departments throughout.
And, on a more coercive tact,
perhaps the federal government
through the Department of Justice
needs to get more involved
in terms of investigating
individual police departments
in states that have a systemic issue.
Effectively over the last few years
the department has stopped investigating
individual police departments.
I can't remember the time
the Department of Justice
issued a consent decree against
individual police departments
to help enforce rights.
And that's a worrying trend,
because that's one of the oversight roles
of the Department of Justice.
And while the federal government should
probably have some oversight role
over state and local police departments,
we don't want the police having
too much oversight over you.
So, if you're using the
internet out in the wild,
and you don't want the police
looking at your internet traffic,
you should definitely try Express VPN.
For those of you who don't already know,
a VPN basically creates a secure tunnel
from whatever device you're
using and the internet,
keeping your digital privacy intact.
And it's a big issue because
every time you connect to
an unencrypted wifi network
at airports, hotels, coffee shops,
and even at home, you're at risk.
Express VPN encrypts
your internet connections
using the highest standards of
encryption currently available.
A big problem in the US is that
ISPs track and sell your
browsing habits to advertisers.
In my experience, Express VPN is also
the fastest VPN by far.
And with Express VPN you can also
reroute your connection to a server
in a country of your choice,
giving you unrestricted access
to parts of the internet
and making geo restrictions
a thing of the past.
Take watching Netflix for example,
say I want to watch one of my favorite
British sci-fi shows about a
time traveling alien doctor.
What can I say?
I'm a fan.
But the selection with me
being in the United States
isn't the same as if I was in the UK.
So, once I switched my VPN, I can watch
pretty much whatever I
want, whenever I want.
Or maybe I want to see what's trending
in YouTube in Belgium or Japan.
I can route my traffic there.
I'm huge in Japan, I assume.
Express VPN also has
24/7 customer support,
which means your questions will be
answered within seconds, not hours.
And you don't have to take my word for it.
Express VPN is rated number one by
TechRadar, CNET, The Verge,
and Comparitech, and many others.
So, if you want to join, just head over
to expressVPN.com/legaleagle right now
and find out how you can
get three months free.
Again, that's expressVPN.com/legaleagle
or just click the link
down in the description.
Plus, clicking on that link
really helps out this channel.
So, do you agree with my analysis?
Are there other ways that
we should reform the police?
Or should we leave the police
just the way that they are?
Leave your objections in the comments
and check out this playlist over here
with all of my other analysis about
legal issues raised in the news today,
and just click on this playlist
and I'll see you in court.